hello in this video we'll talk about d
george syndrome
dejot syndrome which is also known as
22q
11.2 deletion syndrome is a syndrome
which is caused by the deletion
of the small segment of chromosome 22.
so in the chromosome 22 a very small
portion in the q
arm is deleted and the locus is known as
22q 11.2 and as a result of this
deletion
there is d george syndrome so simply d
george syndrome is an inherited
immunodeficiency disorder
we would learn about it in details but
the major facts about these disease is
they have
poorly developed thymus or no thymus at
all
so you can clearly understand that there
would be defects in t
cell production and these individuals
would be immunocompromised
lastly these individuals undergo
cardiac complications so let us look at
some facial features that are distinct
to d george syndrome so this is how our
dijon syndrome patient would look like
he would have small low set ears
short with of the eye openings
enlarged nose tip and a hooded eye
and majorly they have a very long
face so these are some few
characteristics
facial feature of d george syndrome
now this disorder is typically
due to a deletion now
due to this 22 11 q
11 q 2 deletion
there is at least 20 genes
or more than 20 genes are deleted or
affected one of them
or one of the most important of them is
tbx1 gene
tbx1 gene is an important transcription
factor
which is present in the third and fourth
pharyngeal pouch and also it is enriched
in facial structures heart thyroid
parathyroid thymus etc
and they're present while these tissue
tissues are developing
so in d chord syndrome tbx
1 gene is missing and as a result
these structures are compromised so we
can clearly understand
that tbx 1 is highly expressed in the
structure such as heart thyroid
parathyroid etc
and all of these structures would be
somehow perturbed
in a dgs patient
majorly the heart is affected
so this is how a normal heart look like
but in the dgs patient you would see
ventricular septal defect
or a true ventricular canal defect these
kind of defects are pretty common
in d george syndrome patients other than
heart there would be complications
associated with thyroid and parathyroid
gland
now let me tell you another important
feature of d george syndrome which is
present
of a cleft pellet so here
a opening or cleft in the roof of the
mouth plate
is seen so you can see the
the upper lips are not totally joined to
each other
now as a result of this there could be
difficulties in swallowing
and there could be also speech related
or verbal
difficulties characteristic sound might
come out
so this kind of difficult this kind of
differences are present in dijon
syndrome
questions now although most of the
uh dijord syndrome patients suffer to
some extent immunodeficiency
but the the extent of immunodeficiency
could be
variable now the most important thing
is thymus
is not present or partially present in
these george syndrome patients
so you can clearly understand t cells
which develop from the thymus
is not present in case of these dijon
syndrome or even if presents at a very
small
extent so all the t cell mediated
functions of the immune systems are
abrogated
and these patients are more vulnerable
towards opportunistic pathogen bacteria
etc
now thymic transplantation and passive
antibody treatment
might be beneficial for these patients
but this
is not a long-term solution so these
individuals
have their cell mediated immunity
severely compromised
as well as the b cell mediated uh
humoral immunity is also compromised
because b cell activation requires t
cell so that is why these individuals
are vulnerable to bacterial and fungal
infection
so i hope that summarize a little bit
about d george syndrome and this is a
very short video
but if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe
thank you and if you want to join my
unacademic course use my code epi 10 to
get a 10
discount thank you guys